I'm really happy
that we're going
to be able to have time to talk
with Film Editor Andrew Marcus.
Andrew's career spans
over three decades.
His films include Howard's
End, American Psycho,
Under the Tuscan Sun,
Dirty Dancing, Sing Street,
Isn't Tt Romantic
and, of course,
the film we're celebrating
today - Hedwig and the Angry
Inch for its 20th anniversary.
So, Andrew, let's
talk about Hedwig.
I'm super excited.
I love Hedwig and I love every
opportunity to talk about it.
Fantastic!
So I think the first thing
we'd like to know is,
and I think kind of like
actors, there's probably
somewhat of a casting
process for editors
where people are looking for a
certain aesthetic or whatever.
So tell us how you came
on board and how you came
to be chosen for this project.
Well, I have a very
circuitous route to Hedwig.
I was doing period
movies in London.
All the Merchant Ivory and
Kenneth Branagh movies.
And I really wanted to
break out of that world
and do more edgy projects.
So I started working
with a company called
Muse Productions in
Los Angeles, and they
did Trees Lounge, Two Girls
and a Guy, Virgin Suicides.
And we were looking for
projects to produce.
And I had seen
Hedwig at SqueezeBox,
and then I had seen
it at Westbeth,
and when it opened
at Jane Street,
I brought all the
producers at Muse
and some of their investors
to a number of productions.
I was really excited about
trying to bring it to film.
Unfortunately, Jersey
Productions, Danny Devito's
company was also
involved, and we got out
of the running really quickly.
But then when I was
editing American Psycho,
we were editing in
the apartment complex
that Christine Vachon
lived in, and my husband
was working for Marlene,
Christine's wife,
and she just casually
mentioned that she
was going to produce Hedwig,
and I literally stalked her
every day to get the job.
And I did.
Eventually.
That's a great story,
and I love again
the idea of you going
from Merchant Ivory
into Hedwig and American Psycho.
So you definitely got
to make your transition.
Congratulations.
That's not always easy to do.
What were some of the
biggest challenges
that you faced with Hedwig?
And, you know, it's such
a wide variety of styles,
and types of things going on.
There's the stage shows,
there's the animation.
I mean, it's a really
visual, diverse film.
And how did you make the
editing style all fit together,
and what were your
challenges as you
began combining all of this?
I mean, to John's credit,
he had workshopped it
at Sundance for a
year before we began.
And he storyboarded it and
he's an incredible student
of cinema.
And so, a lot of the challenges
of adapting it to film he had
worked out before I came on.
There weren't a lot of
challenges filmically.
The real challenges
were on stage
John was Tommy
Gnosis and Hedwig.
And then when we had another
actor playing Tommy Gnosis.
That in the end it's very easy
if you're the same character
to merge into the same person.
But I think that our biggest
challenge was creating
an ending that was moving
where they became one,
as in the Origin of
Love story, but they
were two separate actors.
And that took a long
time to work out,
and it took a lot of sort
of reediting and rethinking
how the ending was working.
What about the
animation part of it?
What was the challenge in that,
and how was that accomplished?
I would say that
wasn't a challenge.
Working with Emily Hubley was
one of the greatest experiences
of my career.
She's a complete genius,
and because the animations
were roughly projected
while we were shooting it,
we had a lot of the
animations as stills
before we even began shooting.
So we had it roughed
out, and it was sort
of an embarrassment of riches.
The real challenge was
how do you cut away
from a great performance
to animation?
And where do you want
to be at any one time
because to tell the
story of Origin of Love
you really need the
animations, but you also
want to hear John singing
it, and the band playing it.
So that was the real challenge.
Finding that balance.
We noticed that you also
have a credit for Second Unit
Director, and I'm not
sure that that's always
the case with Film Editors.
How did that come about?
I was a Second Unit Director
in a lot of the Merchant Ivory
movies, and on Kenneth
Branagh's movies, and on Psycho.
So it's really easy for an
editor to do second unit
because you've cut
the sequence, and you
know exactly what pieces
you need to piece in.
It makes sense for
editors to do it.
I'm surprised more editors don't
do it, but I love doing it.
Things like the gummy
bears, all the insert shots
like the candy going to Luther,
the gummy bears, the bathtub
scene, and that sort of thing.
So you worked with Hedwig
and the gummy bears.
That is true dexterity.
I'm very impressed with that.
It was a challenge getting
the gummy bears to steam up.
[LAUGHING]
That's fantastic.
Thank you.
So I assume that you were
brought onto the film
even as it was in production.
Where you on the
set for the shoot?
I was actually cutting in a
Winnebago on set at all times,
and it was such a
great experience
because I was
running to the camera
when they would ask questions.
"Do we need this shot?
Do we need that shot?"
People could come
to the Winnebago
and see a sequence
as we were going.
And because of that, there was
a real sense of camaraderie
that you don't get any
more really on film sets.
We all were staying
in the same place.
We all spent weekends together.
There's a whole sequence when
Hedwig teaches Tommy, goes over
his record collection, and
that was shot on a Saturday
in the house I was staying in.
We just did some
guerilla filmmaking.
Fantastic.
I get that sense of
camaraderie, and I
know that that's something
that you don't experience
on every film, and the ones
you do, I think people really
cherish even all the more just
because of the fun you have
and the family
that you build so--
We were all great
friends for a long time
and still can see
each other and talk.
That's great.
So as an editor you end
up watching the film
multiple times.
So what are some of
the favorite moments
that you still get a big
kick out of as you're
thinking about Hedwig.
I think the most successful
transformation from stage
to film is Wig in a Box.
It's sort of a perfect
film moment where--
When I did Isn't It Romantic, we
talked about favorite makeover
scenes, and there are
lists all over the internet
about favorite makeover scenes.
And I think Wig in
a Box and Clueless
come up as the two
favorite makeover scenes.
I think Ari and costumes, the
production design, the camera,
everything sort of came
together in that scene
and made it really special,
and really cinematic.
And really kind of
thrilling for the audience.
So you mentioned
production design.
You have any memories of
working with Therese DePrez
or any reflections on her
work seeing it as an editor
and how it worked for you?
I loved working with Therese.
She taught me so much
about production design,
and the value of
production design.
When we did Bilgewaters, which
is where Hedwig was booked
to perform, it was a
decommissioned Red Lobster
outside of Toronto,
and she redecorated
it to show that it was a
different place every time.
One day, I picked up
the menus, and she
had written these extensive
menus that were hysterical.
Everything was a
joke on the menu
and you never saw
the menu on camera,
but that was just
her level of detail.
The motto of the restaurant
was 'Bilgewaters -
yesterday's seafood
at tomorrow's prices.'
And you never saw that, but
there is just sort of a gift
to everybody on set
that she gave us.
I love the idea of
that being in your head
as you're performing on
the set, and sitting there
in that location.
A decommissioned Red Lobster.
I Love all the things that would
put into your head as an actor.
And it's great for extras,
it's great for everybody.
It just adds a
whole other layer.
Fantastic.
So we're in a very unusual time.
Very particular time.
And at the same time,
this film at 20 years
still has a resonance, and still
has I think messages for us
to be reminded of regularly.
So tell me, how do you
feel this film still
impacts 20 years later?
I think the film was
way ahead of itself.
And people didn't
quite understand
what John was getting at
when he was making it.
I think John was
always really clear
that Hedwig isn't a
drag queen, Hedwig
is a genderqueer performer.
And the whole notion of
genderqueer, and gender
fluidity, it's now
taken root and people
accept it completely.
But I remember bringing really
like sophisticated people
to the show.
I brought someone who is
like a part of Andy Warhol's
Factory as a possible investor
and they didn't get it at all.
And I think it was just way,
way, way ahead of its time.
What it was saying.
What it was trying to achieve.
I also think one of the
sad things when it came out
was gay rock 'n roll
wasn't a big thing.
And so I remember somebody
saying it was too rock
'n roll for the gays, and
too gay for the rockers.
And I think now it's found
its place completely,
and it's not shocking at all.
I just showed it to
my 13-year-old twins
and they think it's the
greatest thing I've worked on.
Finally, something cool
that I've worked on.
[LAUGHTER]
Wonderful.
They'll grow to love
Howard's End as time passes.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, I do want to ask you
this since you brought it
up, and in talking about it
just now, what as an editor,
what was working with
the music, and what
were your impressions
of the music aspects
of Hedwig, and how that fit in,
and the contribution that that
made to the film?
I mean, I love
working with music.
I'm a secret music
theater queen,
and I just think songs convey
emotion way better than words.
And whether it's like Dirty
Dancing, which I worked on,
or Sing Street, or
I think anything
is enhanced with music.
And so it was a real privilege
to work on this because I
think the songs are so amazing.
But, it also gives
you a shortcut.
You don't have to do
a lot of exposition.
You don't have to do--
When you were asking me about
what favorite scenes I had,
I think Wig in a Box
is a favorite because
of the makeover aspect.
But even re-watching it for
this, when Hedwig puts on--
gives the wig to Miriam
in Midnight Radio,
and then she falls into people,
I tear up at that still.
And I think you couldn't
get that level of emotion
in just a dialogue scene.
It's completely conveyed by
the combination of music,
and acting, and
performance, and it takes it
to a whole other level.
Well, it's really been fun
having a look at Hedwig
from the insights
of the Film Editor.
I'm really always happy to have
as many of the collaborators,
and many of the perspectives
talking about a film.
And I really appreciate
your taking time
with us for this
conversation today.
Thanks so much, Andrew.
Thank you.